[موسيقى]
هذه المشاهد ليست في غزه بل في جنوب لبنان
الذي يعيش ظروفا غير عاديه قرا باكملها
اصبحت خاليه من سكانها تركوا منازلهم
واعمالهم ومدارسهم وذهبوا الى اماكن اكثر
امنا ومنذ الثامن من اكتوبر وبالتزامن مع
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه تتعرض قرى جنوب
لبنان لقصف
يومي الامم المتحده قدرت اعداد النازحين
باكثر من
83000 نازح ما يشكل ضغطا كبيرا عليهم وعلى
المناطق المستضيفه على حد سواء خصوصا ان
لبنان يعيش انهيارا اقتصاديا غير مسبوق
وازمه وصفت بانها الاخطر على مدى تاريخه
المعاصر خسائر فادحه لحقت في القطاع
الزراعي العصب الاقتصادي لقرى الجنوب
ومصدر رزق نحو 70% من سكانه كثير من
المزارعين لم يتمكنوا من جان محاصيل موسم
الخريف الذي تصادف مع بدء هذه الحرب مئات
الهكتارات دمرت بفعل القصف الاسرائلي ايضا
بما في ذلك اكثر من 50 الف شجره زيتون عمر
بعضها مئات
السنين الضرر لحق ايضا بقطاع التعليم 5
مدرسه على الاقل اغلقت ابوابها واستهدف
القصف بعضها ما اجبر اكثر من 8000 طالب
على ترك مقاعدهم الدراسيه المرافق العامه
لم تسلم ايضا شبكات المياه والكهرباء
والصرف الصحي بالاضافه الى الطرقات التي
حال قصفها دون وصول الخدمات
الطبيه الصحفيون الموجودون لتغطيه الاحداث
كانوا ايضا هدفا اسرائيليا اكثر من مره
حيث قتل ثلاثه منهم واصيب
اخرون ومع مرور اكثر من 12 يوما ما زال
الجنوبيون ينتظرون نهايه هذه الحرب للعوده
الى قراهم والى حياتهم التي كانوا
عليها